wednesday show we do appreciate it
uh and if you really want to help us out
check out our clip channel youtube.com
rotc media become a patron
patreon.com we're not
sorry uh oh he looks here i think here
we're talking about him i don't like
that
um cam get pieces who do you think you
are
what's up buddy hope you're feeling
better uh it says alexa cbd help with
the leg but it also kept me from
losing my twitter account maybe
nightwave should try some
ah that's fine don't slip on any ice
this year oh
[ __ ] you take that oh yeah
i mean so what's how many how many
[ __ ] accounts have i lost at this
point
um mike we have another credible threat
from day of the rake we have another
credible threat
this is a 100 credible threat i thought
this was behind us man
well no mike if anything
it's in front of us oh god this is bad
revenge of the sis i underestimated you
[Music]
protect me protect me dark lord
protect me box days we didn't think
you'd have those kind of connections
but they won't be enough we're just
going to go into hiding
look at him look at him
copy that view just the premise that
we're people hunting these guys yes
it's very bad for me when i watch these
sketches it really is
my like the way when i watch it it's
like
in my mind this guy is just delusional
lunatic
you know and you're like i don't know i
do what are you doing
nobody's hunting you they're gonna find
me it's like
nobody i love this
[ __ ] they won't be enough we're just
gonna go into hiding
[Laughter]
copy that vfm too i'm approaching teddy
tower
that's a tree house it's a treehouse
a good underground base of opera you
know have you got to lay low
rob's got a good point the fact you're
laughing at this just means we're asking
for more trouble you're right we should
be taking this more seriously
you're actually taking it more seriously
we should be taking a guy named dave the
rake was serious
dfm too i'm approaching teddy tower it's
also funny because this is how some of
their followers really
are like it's just they're so serious
and you're like dude relax
[Music]
shitty little chair
karate through
what's a karate throw
literally karate throw literally just
throws the word karate in front of any
action
this is karate drink
[Music]
[Laughter]
i just also love how realistic this is
because if you did go out to an old tree
house there would be like some shitty
chair that's dirty and too small karate
throw
that's a good throw that rock is you oh
so sneaky
[Music]
vfm2 informed the dark lord that all the
ingredients for the berserker sauce have
been found
is it a weapon or are you going to eat
the berserker sauce i would arrest i
wouldn't eat that mushroom by the way
if i were you why not oh [ __ ] he's in
the chat there isn't he says don't laugh
he's in the chat
right now i'm sorry [ __ ] stop don't
don't laugh and stop
please don't hurt us hey come on bro
we're [ __ ] we're laughing because
we're scared yeah i i laugh when i get
nervous
what's berserker sauce
[ __ ] me man all the ingredients for the
berserker sauce have been found
we're going to redouble our training
efforts
[Music]
by the way i don't i don't want him by
the way don't
clarify i don't want to know where you
live i don't know where he lives but
whatever it is gives him a nice stream
it's a nice little natural area to go
hang out in apparently
the rake says berserker sauce is for
spaghetti
oh [ __ ] i don't know how many takes he
has to do
cry cry crying
[Music]
hi this for the long haul we're going to
take it to the next level
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
he's waterboarding himself it's training
dude it's doing its own hand okay
it's training you are not ready
for this spaghetti the final showdown's
coming
[ __ ] man hey you know what can you do
man
they can't be stopped if you want to
subscribe the day of the race day the
rate's amazing
let me let me post let me post the other
regular link here this
is the lake taylor rake um so i've
actually gone in and watched this show
he puts on a very good show it's nothing
to do with his craziness
no i know he's just chilling this is a
pretty cool show
if you want to subscribe to him there it
is day of the rake oh
[ __ ] very funny man that is very well
done
oh [ __ ]